thank you very much indeed for joining
us today
um the interest in Ai and its governance
uh is uh is very intense at the moment
and just this morning the government has
set out or is about to publish a white
paper setting out its proposed
approach to the governance uh of AI
white paper invites responses before
it's confirmed and the committee will be
feeding into that as well but perhaps I
might ask both of our Witnesses just to
comment on I guess what's the the
headline
indication from the white paper which is
that rather than giving responsibility
for AI governance to a single new AI
regulator the government intends to
empower existing regulators and
obviously there are several that exist
in the education sector do you have any
initial reaction to that Professor
looking and then Mr julu
forward and I can understand the
rationale behind that empowering
existing authorities
my concern is that
I worry that existing authorities don't
have the in-depth knowledge about the
technology to really be able to do a
good job I don't mean that in any
insulting way to them whatsoever but the
technology is moving at a pace it's
increasingly complex even the people who
are developing developing it don't
always understand the implications of
exactly what it does and so I hope
in parallel with empowering those
existing bodies there will be a
tremendous effort put into making sure
that they actually do have the skills
the knowledge
the understanding of the technology in
order to really be able
to do their jobs with Force because I
think what we do have to recognize is
that
AI is a technology I'm sure you all do
recognize this it's not going away it's
only going to become more prevalent used
by more people and have even greater
impact so it's super important that we
make sure that people really do
understand enough about it to be able to
do that regulatory work indeed and The
Regulators in in the school setting one
things of ofsted and off-qual are there
others that you think might be
in scope for this in in the schools part
of Education
I think
this is a bigger question
um
I don't think we put enough attention
into educating people about AI it's
therefore really hard for me to point to
any other organizations I feel that do
have the knowledge both about education
and about AI so it's a bigger issue I'm
sorry if that's not no such a factory
answer it's just a key issue for me is
the lack of attention that we've put
educating people about AI Beyond doing a
great job at investing in stem and
investing particularly in universities
to make sure we've got the technical
skills about AI but that's not the same
thing
okay well the purpose of inquiry is to
to make some recommendations perhaps I
can ask the same question just to start
off with uh to miss cristojulu
um any any initial thoughts given I
don't think it's even formally published
yet but we know
um what's in the The Press as to this
intended approach does that does that
ring rights which is that ring with you
that this is the the right approach
I would
have was in one of the challenges with
the new generative AI Tools in
particular is they are very complex and
as you say you're absolutely right
sometimes their own developers don't
really know exactly what they can and
can't do so there is a a huge level of
complexity there
um so yeah there has to be a concern
that existing Regulators uh you know
where they had their expertise you know
having said that if we're looking at
within education specifically I know
that offqual have um
looked at this you know a few years ago
and looked at the potential for AI to to
Mark assessments I know they've
something that's on their radar and I
think the immediate implication of a lot
of the generative AI the large language
models is probably going to involve
assessment
so it probably makes sense if you want
to move quickly that yeah you give you
you you you empower the existing
Regulators to look at it and I do think
one of my other concerns as well is the
complexity of it one of my other
concerns is that a lot of organizations
moving very very slowly on this
and whereas the speed of the adoption of
the technology in society is much
quicker than the tech company and you
know I feel like there's um you know
there are organizations who will end up
setting up a working group to think
about in a year's time and by that point
you could have almost every student
using it so this is important yeah speak
speed does matter absolutely good okay
um so just on this point given that um
this white paper's just being launched
today I'm just going to take a couple of
questions on this before we go into some
of your experience of AI in education so
starting with Stephen Metcalf thank you
very much good morning um it was just
something um you said Professor luck in
which was around the knowledge people's
knowledge of AI
um and the lack of an understanding how
would you do you have any suggestions
perhaps of how we might improve that
generally within the wider public so I
think it is important they understand
what AI is rather than just take their
reference frame from what they might
have seen on television or film
absolutely
I think
watershed moment that
it's not that chat GPT
or any of these generative AI tools
are cutting-edge technology they have
been round for several years the huge
difference in what has happened is that
it's the first time in the history of a
human race
that people at scale have had access to
an AI tool that they can use it's very
usable it's there it's just like when
Google for I'm old enough to remember
when Google first appeared as a search
engine it was so different to anything
else we'd ever had and so people are
using Ai and they know they're using AI
they've been used by AI for many years
so I think we mustn't underestimate the
significance of what's Happening Here
in that scale and therefore we have to
recognize the scale of the need for
education so we do have to look in
schools and colleges and universities
workplace training to think about well
what is it people really do need to
understand about AI in order for them to
be able to use effectively and stay safe
thinking about your current well I'm
sorry I've got an abnormally high heart
rate I'm not sure
I hope we haven't caused that so far
that's because I do feel very strongly
that we do need to look across the board
at Education and Training
I love programming I love technology but
not everybody does and so I think we
have to be careful not to approach it by
expecting everybody to want to
understand the intricacies of the
technology how it works what it does in
understanding the maths behind neural
networks or learning how to program in
Python or whatever it might be lovely
stuff for those who like it but we need
to find a way to help everybody to want
to understand what this can do in very
general terms what it means to be
artificially intelligent and what I
would suggest is that a way of doing
that is to think very carefully about
what it means to be intelligent as a
human
and then understand the differences
absolutely at the final tiny question
which is really around therefore
um
how do we teach a dig that using our own
intelligence a degree of skepticism
because actually I as an experiment
asked it uh chat GPT to write a 300 word
biography about me
which it did but it was inaccurate in
almost every it was me but it was
inaccurate in all the detail
but no one else would know that
necessarily yes so there it almost needs
to come with a health warning it does it
does I have to laugh I asked about Ai
and education and who should one talk to
about Ai and education and I felt very
flattered when I was number one
and I had the same experience yes a
healthy skepticism is important and that
comes from understanding that
at all liked at GPT does not understand
a word it produces it has no conception
of how those words apply in the real
world and once you grasp that you can
start to become much more skeptical and
once you learn how to write the sorts of
prompts
you know the prompt engineering as we
might call it then you soon find out
exactly what it can't do it's incredibly
useful I use it it's ever so useful but
it's just recognizing that this is
information collation it's not knowledge
it's not understanding it's collating
vast amounts of information
and often incorrectly absolutely so
we'll get more accurate though it will
but there's nothing artificial and
there's nothing intelligent about AI
thank you on on this theme uh Dawn thank
you chair
um thank you both just a question
there's the quickly I think
um Daisy you mentioned like okay we need
to do something quickly this is the way
to do it is it
staying in a ball and is it the best way
are we going to get the best results are
these organizations equipped to be able
to educate people as Rose was saying or
to protect people in regards to AI yeah
absolutely that that is a really good
point
um and
I have to say you know that this the
speed of the way it's moving is quite
disconcerting it's been disconcerting
for us as an organization
um and one of the challenges just to go
back to that previous point about
education is
how do you educate people when it's
moving so rapidly
and when also there are genuine debates
between people within AI about exactly
where it will end up and I don't want to
you know I'm not going to make huge
predictions here but I think the
important thing to note is that people
have quite strong disagreements about
where it's going and there are some
people who will say it is only going to
get better you know yes it's making
mistakes now but it's it's going to be
pretty Flawless within a year or two
there are other people who are saying
that's not the case
and actually
um it's you know it doesn't kind of have
true understanding and therefore
actually some of the things it's
producing a bit like magic tricks and
it's not going to keep developing at
PACE and I guess the reality is we don't
know and therefore educating people and
regulating is hard in that level of
uncertainty
I think what probably is important to
move quickly and I think with some
things perhaps you don't want to move
quickly because of the uncertainty so
there's an argument in some cases for
slowing down
I think in the places where Regulators
have to move quickly are in those areas
where I would say within education it
could have an immediate impact and
probably already is starting to have an
impact which is particularly if students
are starting to use it to write work and
hand in work I think that's almost the
most pressing immediate need where you
would say well regulators and schools
and universities need to be thinking
about that and they need to be thinking
about their assessment models and I
don't always think there are easy
answers to some of those questions then
they're not straightforward and
institutions that's what I think does
have to be high up on their radar like
it worries me as I say when I see
institutions thinking oh we'll put a
working group together about this in six
months you'll know it's happening now
like you need to be thinking about this
now
so there may not be easy answers it does
propose challenges but I do think for
those areas that are immediately
impacted by them we do have to be
thinking about it quickly just one quick
follow-up question please to both of you
um what is the one thing that we must do
sort of in this area to ensure
safeguarding
here do you want to go that's a very
good question
um what is the one thing we must do
um
I mean look people have discussions
about about schools have a lot of
autonomy about what they do I'm thinking
about this specifically in the schools
and and and and and and University sort
of sector schools and universities do
have autonomy and I think it's good that
they have all that autonomy
um and they you know want to be making
their decision they've got the latitude
to make decisions on these but
yeah I'm not sorry I wouldn't be saying
I think there should be something you
want to mandate but perhaps it does have
to be something where there's some kind
of some kind of formal conversation or
something between particularly maybe
off-corn schools about
um the impact on assessment and in terms
of the safeguarding
again I'm thinking about this within the
education schools context
you've pointed out already that it makes
a lot of mistakes there's also risks of
it a lot of people have pointed out the
way that some of the yeah it can go
Rogue and it can start to say some quite
dangerous things
so
yeah those are things that that you know
if there's I don't know if there needs
to be some kind of central sort of set
of advice as I say you know the schools
have autonomy and I think in lots of
ways that's a good thing
um but I think there are important
things about the impact on assessment
and the impact as you point out on
safeguarding and the kind of dangerous
things it can say we need to be taking
those very seriously and they're not
necessarily easy issues to address thank
you I think the one thing that we have
to work out how to do is change the
balance of power
at the moment the power is with the tech
companies
we are here talking about this because a
tech company has produced and made
available a technology to everybody yeah
we've known this technology has been
around for several years
people like myself and Daisy too who've
been talking about the need to to think
about
Ai and education for a long time but it
took this moment to wake people up so we
have to find a way of Shifting the power
and for me the only way I think you can
shift the power is through education
through really helping people to
understand and I do feel now I know and
I haven't had a chance to read the white
paper but I know there's an idea around
a Sandbox in it and that might be a
really useful educational tool if we
could make it an educational tool
because I think one way we might start
to shift that Power Balance is by
joining regulation and education
together
so making the way the regulation is
developed an educational process so that
then people start to to realize why they
need to care about this because we'll
never ever keep up I mean I completely
agree with Daisy prediction is difficult
I think I could quite confidently
predict the technology will continue to
advance it will get better but I agree
it won't be perfect and it'll do things
we're not expecting
we can't predict exactly how humans will
react to it
we can predict that a lot of people will
want to make money out of it and we'll
make a lot of money out of it and many
of them will be unscrupulous
we can't predict precisely what that
impact will have on people other than
it's going to be potentially bad
we can also predict that there are so
many good things that come out of this
so look at the things we can be sure of
and try and work out how we educate
people to be able to cope with the
uncertainty of the things we can't be
sure of and I do feel
having an educational aspect to
regulation might be a way
of starting to shift that Power Balance
because as I said to
your first question Stephen we do
actually really need to educate
everybody but of course that's a huge
task so we've got to start somewhere
can I come in one other thing actually
um it's very brief because we do need to
get on to um if there is one thing you
know the one thing you could do I
hesitate to say this because I don't
think it's sort of that realistic but
the one thing that I think we as an
organization and a lot of organizations
would love to know is particularly in
the case of open AI how they've trained
their model and they haven't released
that so they're called openai but
there's a lot of closed aspects of what
they're doing and that makes it
incredibly hard to evaluate what it does
and incredibly hard to evaluate how it
produces its results so there is an
element of AI which there's just
inevitably a bit of a black box that
you'll never even the developers
themselves might not know how it's
producing its outputs but there's an
element of AI where they could be more
open and certainly they've published
some aspects of How It's trained but not
the full details and so I think that
will be a really future area of
Regulation not just in this country but
globally of uh to what extent do you
force organizations like open AI to
actually open up and share how they
train their models I do note that one of
the five principles that the government
have set out today for The Gardens of AI
is transparency and explainability so um
and if that's to be applied to
Regulators we'll want to go into some
more detail on those uh thank you for
that that was the useful kind of snap
reaction uh to what's being put out
today what we want to do for the rest of
the session is to benefit from your
understanding of how AI is currently
being applied and what what seems to be
around the corner in schools so perhaps
I could start with Miss Chris ludu and
just describe the the reality now of the
deployment of AI in school settings as
you see it and if we keep the answers
brief because we've got as we've seen
lots of members eager to answer to ask
lots of questions
line you know the features here it's
just unevenly distributed um there's an
uneven distribution and I think there's
some teachers and some students who have
started using it a lot and there's some
who kind of haven't heard of it so it's
it's it's spreading
um I think in in terms of you know what
are the areas where people are using it
and looking at it well you've got the
kind of the problematic areas where
children students using it to cheat and
I think that's already starting to see
that that's an issue you've got issues
can teachers use it to plan resources
and to create questions how it is being
used at the moment for those of us not
in the education world how is it being
used by teachers by teachers and
students yeah so as I say I think my
teachers you've got someone coming up
next on the next panel um you've got
teachers who are using it to create
resources so a lot of what teachers
spend their time on will be planning
lessons and creating resources and I
know that lots of them will use chat GPT
um to help with that so I'll give one
example I think it does work really well
it is very good at summarizing at Tech
summarizing so if you take a sort of
complex text maybe from Wikipedia
something that you're kind of about for
the accuracy so Wikipedia is a good
example if you pop it into chat gbt and
say can you rewrite this in this for so
it's appropriate for a 10 year old
it does quite a good job so that's quite
useful so things like that it can do and
something like that it doesn't tend to
make too many mistakes either you can
you know you because you're kind of
giving it the information so something
like that can be can be pretty useful
I've also you know seen lots of teachers
and lots of educational organizations
using it to create questions this is
where it gets more problematic you know
the more sort of open you make it the
more you give it more latitude it does
make a lot of Errors makes an awful lot
of Errors
um and you know I've got a little
collection of them that we're sort of
storing up when you say questions
questions for students as part of
teaching or questions for exams of
teaching so for example you know at the
end of a lesson on Pythagoras Theorem
you want to give students a few
questions and maybe you've got some
already that you've created but it's
always nice to have more and you might
want to mix it up a bit and so you ask
chat GPT can you give me a question
about Pythagoras is theorem and it will
do it the problem is it makes mistakes
and I mentioned Pythagoras Theorem
because that's one of the ones we've
looked at and it's a really baffling
mistake that it keeps making where it
essentially confuses 14 squared and 13
squared
um 13 squared is 100 69 or 14 squared is
196 and I'm convinced just mixing up the
numbers dyslexic
you know I don't want to say that but
yeah who knows um so what's you know you
want if you'd want to use it in schools
it's nowhere near just being able to
automate and put it out there and how
widespread is it so you say that it can
be used to generate questions at the end
of you know a lesson how widespread
would you say that is being used
currently by a biology I genuinely don't
know I haven't seen any data on it I
would suggest that it's I would say the
minute probably
um a small percentage of quite
enthusiastic teachers I would suggest
but I don't know I haven't seen any data
on it that's my feeling Professor
looking what do you have a perception as
to what the current uses are at the
moment and how widespread they might be
you mean the current users have changed
okay so it's quite a long history
there's a great deal of difference
between what happens in research and
what happens in practice and I'm going
to talk about what happens in practice
because I think that's what you're
interested in so
two
characteristics of AI are super
important here adaptivity and autonomy
so we can use AI to build adaptive
systems
that will help a learner progress at
their own speed so to speak and there
are a lot of them around
um
they might alter the quality sorry it
might alter the difficulty of the task
the students set in order to better meet
that student's need they might alter the
nature of the support the hints the tips
that are given in order to support that
student to be successful and then they
can give good quality feedback to
teachers many of them have been around
for quite a long time there's lots of
data to suggest they're pretty good not
all of them the well-designed ones are
pretty good and studies that have been
conducted with those systems have
demonstrated that they are as good at
tutoring not teaching tutoring as a
human tutor when working with a whole
class remembering that the AI is working
one-to-one so they're not as good as a
human working on a one-to-one
teaching versus tutoring just explain
the difference so teaching is a far
richer Act activity than tutoring
tutoring is just part of it
very useful
because if you can
[Music]
have part of the teaching job and that
can give you as a teacher really good
feedback about your students then you
know as the human teacher where to offer
your support in particular so very
useful technologies that have been
around for a while
just to pause on that for a second so um
would it be right in thinking that in
say a mixed ability class that was
studying a particular subject
um it might be possible to have
tailored to the particular either level
or learning styles learning preferences
of individual students for that common
subject different approaches would that
would that be that's exactly what I'm
talking about and the important part is
that you get feedback as a teacher and
you get feedback as a learner you can
also get feedback as a parent so you
have a British company like Century Tech
is a very popularly used platform
um not just in the UK also are there
other companies too in the US Carnegie
universities Carnegie Learning have
produced these kind of systems for
several decades and improved them all
the time so we know that there are also
ways in which AI can help teachers
track down the most appropriate
resources for their students so a
different kind of adapting so it's not
adapting to the student it's adapting to
the teachers needs for those students if
you see what a difference is not
directly teaching it's just helping the
teacher find the resources that are out
there and available that best meet their
needs so these kind of systems have also
been around we've also got AI being used
to
um
analyze and interpret students facial
expressions students voice data mainly
in the University sector but we have
systems that are being used that aren't
just research tools whereby we know the
combination of data captured about
facial expression when combined with
data captured about voice
is much more reliable than either of
those
modalities individually at helping you
understand if a student is particularly
stressed or anxious you don't need to
watch things you know and therefore if
you are for example a counseling AI you
can adapt what you're doing to that
student's needs so there's a lot of
stuff out there that is being used it's
not Daisy is so right it's absolutely
not evenly distributed because it all
costs money
the other type of AI that is being used
but exactly as you've said it depends on
the teacher and their enthusiasm just
the normal tools like you know dictation
AI is really good at transcription these
days
um things like voice activated personal
assistance where you get your students
talking maybe in a foreign language does
the does the voice activated assistant
understand them oh that's interesting no
it doesn't so tools that are readily
available for teachers who understand a
little bit they can see how they can
integrate them into the lessons but
again it's not evenly spread out but it
would be a mistake to think that this
isn't out there already it is exactly
well that's extremely helpful and
municipalities had a long interest in
this predecessor committee published a
report and algorithms in decision making
and so it's our inquiry is very much in
a tradition of advice to the government
on this
um perhaps just um a final word on given
what you've described as the current
deployment is there any evidence
that AI improves student outcomes
art is a really interesting question
there is evidence that we can improve
student outcomes
with the kind of AI That's now being
developed
that can track the learning process not
just the learning product but a lot of
these are not necessarily quite
available at scale yet but they some of
them are just starting to come out
and it's certainly there is a growing
body of evidence that for students who
might have been falling through the net
they can be helped
to be brought back
into the pack if you see what I mean
sorry it's a very good but you get what
I'm saying you know so it's not so much
on
the GCSE results going up but certainly
this student might now actually have a
chance of sitting that GCSE where they
didn't without it because busy teachers
if they have this technology available
to them are able to make sure that
students who have a particular need can
can learn at their own pace and as a
teacher they get that feedback so yes
and that will get better
well that's very clear thank you very
much I'm going to go to my colleagues
now starting with a former science
follow that's that's very interesting uh
stick quality with
The Hidden about Improvement in student
performance is that controlled
experiments or is it just from
observation and
comparing the previous
most of the evidence that I would
consider to be
good quality is still in the research
space
so
there may be some controlled trials
amongst that the reason I'm hesitating
is they won't necessarily have been
conducted in
the classroom environment and until that
happens you can't be sure exactly what
will and won't play out because it's one
thing for something to work in a lab
environment it's quite another or a
carefully created environment even if it
is a school classroom
but often in these studies what you
don't see is going what's going on
behind the scenes to make it work what
we need is some evaluations of the tools
at scale where we would be able to get
the kind of quality data that you you
are talking about there is we are
starting to see data
but it's the independence of the data
it's really important so a lot of the
data you'll see will come from people
who are building the systems and and I
like to see some independent data as
well but we're starting to see that in
research studies and again that will
grow so expect to see more and more and
as we get better at using AI
to track the learning process
we will see even more important data
coming out about how interventions in a
timely manner
in that learning process will produce
much better learning outcomes but this
is quite new and it's not out there at
scale yet
but let's kind of watch this space I
hope that helps
thank you Greg um so I was introducing
Carol Zay as a former science teacher
and Carol's got some questions
I left teaching eight years ago when I
became an MP and things obviously we
were starting to see the use of some of
these tools in a very basic way whenever
I left teaching is is interesting but
um
I want to ask first of all about
exams now exams I have a kind of
developed over history and exams one of
the reasons the exams were introduced
was to kind of label the playing field
because before that you know you would
have people from privileged backgrounds
being able to go and
um
should send themselves to a university
and and they get uh entry to University
exams allowed a much wider range of
people to access this
we're becoming more aware
um certainly probably over the last 10
years that some people some young people
will struggle in an exam situation and
are not reaching their potential in an
exam situation so we're seeing more the
use of continual assessment
in order to
um to determine uh Awards in in National
exams
having listened to what you're saying
this morning about the use of for
example chat GPT to come up with essays
or
um
assignments
do we need to have a good hard look at
our exam methodology or assessment
methodology once again
so yeah I can take that I mean yeah
obviously I work in assessment that's
this is what we do this is our day job
and like yes I think we do I need to
have a good hard look at how we assess
and I do think that chat GPT has huge
implications for continuous assessment
and coursework I think it's very hard to
see how that continues
and I've heard you know a few
suggestions about different things you
could do but I think you know some of
the people making decisions don't
realize quite how powerful a tool like
chat GPT is
that it is capable of producing original
very hard to detect relatively high
quality responses to any kind of
question and they won't be perfect but
they'll be good enough for a lot of
students
and I think that's means that
uncontrolled assessments you know
assessments where you're not sure how
the students produce that work become
very very problematic so I do think we
have to be thinking that there is a
value in in having exams and having
those traditional exams that you know
that that's how the the students
produced it that it is their own work
that it is their own thinking it is very
very hard to spot chat GPT tasks we did
some research on this we got chat GPT to
write eight responses to a task we ran
recently an assessment of
eight-year-olds writing it was only
eight year olds I know and we're going
to repeat with some older students but
we found first of all that those eight
essays we were doing an assessment with
fifty thousand eight-year-olds the of
those eight pieces I think all of the
ones that we designed you know to be to
be the good ones they came out in like
the top the top few percent so they
essentially reach the limit of that
ceiling we also asked our teachers when
they're assessing them to see if they
could spot them and basically they
couldn't they were more likely to pick
an essay that had been written by a real
child and say that had been written by
chat GPT than they were to spot the chat
GPT essay so it writes very good essays
that are very hard to detect by humans
I've heard people talk about oh can we
get the AI to check the AI like you know
about AI plagiarism Sexes the research
I've seen on that is not encouraging
um we've again sort of tried that you
know tried some of the models that are
out at the minute
um it you know again it doesn't they
don't have high accuracy rates of being
able to spot them so these are the
things that I do think we have to be
looking at and thinking about and I
think there's an element where I think
there's a few educational institutions
who are sticking their heads in the sand
and they want to pretend they want to go
away and I think you've had a problem at
universities probably for years now with
sa Mills because sa Mills have been like
maybe a relatively small percentage I
think people don't pretend it's not
happening you're not gonna be able to
pretend this isn't happening because
it's got the potential for 100 of uh
students to be using it in very rapid
time now there is a question at
universities like will it be able to
produce University level SAS but again
the point is even if it can only produce
some like the 50 60 percentile by
definition that's going to be good
enough for 50 60 of people of students
right that they're going to get some
value from it the other thing about it
is it's just so easy
it's so easy to just type in a question
and get a response yeah I mean I a few
weeks ago give a keynote speech to
um an academic audience and it was about
the use of AI and Healthcare and
um I decided I was going to start this
speech with
a chunk from Chachi PT so I'd asked it
to write my introduction I'd asked it to
include a joke
um which it did so I delivered the first
two minutes from chat GPT with a joke
that everyone laughed along with and at
the end of it I told the audience that
that was chat GPT now of course there
you can see the faces there wasn't quite
a sharp intake of breath but clearly I
delivered something that was
um good enough for an academic audience
and quite disturbingly though add a
couple of my own jokes later in there so
chat GPT does better but and can I maybe
so so there is an issue in terms of us
in terms of how we are assessing but
talks about coursework and essays that's
that's a big issue what about in terms
of the scientific subjects I mean what's
it what can it produce if I if I say a
physics assignment to my students how
how is it going to cope with that so
there was some study data out with gpt4
in the past just few weeks where people
gave it a bunch of the American grad
school exams for a whole range of
subjects
um so yes some science ones and medical
ones Law whatever
I use them all you know it did very well
all of them
um so even yeah I think for something
like physics or things like that it is
very good at solving uh solving those
those questions and answering those
assessments and as I say I personally
would say I think the response to that
has to be we have to be looking at
assessments that are in more controlled
environments and I recognize as in I was
you know I was an English teacher that
for some subjects that is not easy and I
totally understand that particularly
University level where the model of you
know going away and writing an essay is
really important so I'm not pretending
this is going to be straightforward but
I just think as you've pointed out its
ability to produce very good very fluent
Pros it's very hard to distinguish is
something that you cannot ignore
um
you've also analyze chat gpt's
performance at assessing different
pieces of work how to go on with that
right so this is where it's less good so
this is kind of the problem for us at
the moment is that I feel like all the
things that it's good at scale within
education feel like less socially useful
things so it's very good at kind of
basically cheating giving students
essays that are not their own it's very
good at that and you can do that to go
and do it rapidly
for the more socially useful things in
education as I talked about creating
questions but also marking it's not as
good as we'd hoped so we have done the
work to plug chat EBT into our
assessment systems we can now quite
easily compare human judging and AI
judging
um you know quite quite rapidly and it
just it doesn't make the same decisions
as humans it makes quite odd and
baffling decisions
um we don't it's not making the right
decisions at scale and the other thing
about it is and this is where you get
the difference between the kind of old
AI systems and these newer llms is that
the great advantage of kind of previous
AI systems and the narrow AI systems a
lot of which we use in our back office
is that they're reliable they're
repeatable you know you give them a
question one day and they give an answer
and you come back a week later and
they'll give it the same answer which
GPT that is not the case
um and in some ways that's the strength
of it but for something like marking
it's a weakness so you ask it to mark an
essay one day and you'll give it one
Mark and then you come back five minutes
later and ask it again and it gives it
something totally different what about
non-essie marking what about again
talking about science and maths even
even with that again we haven't
experimented with that but I've been
talking to people who have and it does
weird things so for example you'll get
it up and running and you'll think
you've got it working and you'll get it
marking some multiple choice questions
and it'll be giving them all and then
suddenly it'll switch and it'll start
giving half marks
so it does odd things
it's not reliable and everyone keeps
saying oh you know we haven't used we
were waiting for our API chat gpt4 API
key so everything I say here you know
maybe tomorrow we'll get our API 4 key
dpt4 API key and maybe this will all
change but where we are at the minute
from what it's doing
just not doing things reliably enough
and it's not consistent enough and he
makes weird errors and there's no way
you could use it even in I would say
like a low stake system at scale for
actual actually assigning marks to
essays the other concern we haven't said
before I'm not even sure it can count
you know in the process it has of
assigning a number to a mark like we're
not sure how it's doing that and that
goes back to some of the training issues
well it might be a little bit better is
that providing some feedback providing a
kind of General passage of feedback and
that's something we're looking at a
little bit so if I was going to kind of
you know give it a grade I'd say it's
absolutely brilliant at producing essays
for students aren't their own
it's not very good at marking and I'm
giving some sort of General ideas for
feedback I'd give it yes maybe there's
some potential there I'll put that in
the middle of course multiple choice
questions are the easiest for any
teacher to Mark I mean bang bang bang
bang bang bang bang so oh yeah we've
actually built um and that we've been
using for a few years now a narrow AI
system to recognize multiple choice
questions on a grid ticks and crosses
and that worked beautifully it's not
very glamorous but it works very well
and it's very repeatable and it cuts
down teacher's workload so there are
these narrow uses of AI which aren't
very glamorous but are very repeatable
which I think are fantastic and
transparent and we can exist see we've
got a mathematical model we can see
exactly why he's doing what he's doing
and Rose talks about some of those as
well so those models I think there's a
lot of potential there GPT is just at
the minute I think a lot of people
working with it would say it's it's
there's a lot of baffling things about
it
sorry I've just gone in
something's worrying me about this I
think that's true for chat GPT
but a different learning large language
model that was trained on a more
accurate data set would do better at
marketing but I don't think that's the
question
because what you drew attention to was
the fact that originally exams were
introduced to try and bring about
equality
now to my mind we seem to have forgotten
that in some exactly this is a fabulous
opportunity
because to my mind if we now have an AI
that can pass our assessments of course
in the short term we have to do all of
this worrying about how we deal with the
fact that we can't change assessment
overnight so how are we going to deal
with this fact
but longer term in truth
if I can have a system that does not
understand anything and has no idea how
any of this applies to the real world
isn't there something wrong with the
assessment in the first place so Rose I
would fundamentally disagree with that
I've agreed with everything you've said
so far but I think you're wrong on that
um
because this is what it's all about
what does it mean to know something
and I'm afraid our education system
is not based on it may be called
knowledge based curriculum but it's not
it's an information based curriculum
it's beautifully designed and I
understand why people are so committed
to it
but it will not produce people who
really really understand and this is
what chat GPT is drawing our attention
to
because it collates information and it
collates information
much greater bodies of information than
we will ever be able to collate
and what's happened here is that over
the years
we have of course developed AI in our
own image because we don't have another
image of intelligence we've only got our
own image of intelligence so we build it
in our own image and we build it to do
the things that we value
now I think we have to have a serious
think long term
what is it to be intelligent as a human
what are the real characteristics of
human intelligence that we want our
populations to have
and surely they are not the ones that we
can easily automate surely they are the
ones that we cannot easily automate and
believe me there are a lot of them I'm
old enough to have been working in a
computer science and AI department when
IBM's big
chess playing machine beat Gary Casper
off at chess and I remember the
excitement people were a hoop we've
cracked it we've cracked intelligence we
can beat Gary Casper off at chess yay us
almost as much huge business chat GPT
and then over the coming months and
years people realize that some of the
things that we took for granted vision
for example much much harder
to do it's taken us decades
and we're still not perfect than chess
but we thought chess was a signifier in
intelligence we need to to look at what
it is to be humanly intelligent we need
to work out because if we don't get that
right we won't work out the right
relationship that humans must have to
artificially intelligence systems
because we don't want to repeat we want
to use these systems to make us smarter
that's the most important thing
I'm aware we could talk about this all
day but
um
which is where you started because it
might help us if we get it right and we
use these great techniques for analyzing
learning processes and being able to
highlight some of these uniquely human
features of our intelligence we might
open up
you know qualifications to populations
that have previously been denied them
it's a fantastic opportunity but we have
to recognize
that we've got to move on from where we
are now now miss Christian Louboutin um
dissent to something that uh professor
said supposed to explain I think lots of
what Rose has said earlier on I grew a
lot quite a bit of what you said there
I'll just see that the disagreement I do
agree absolutely that we need to be
focusing on real human understanding and
I would also agree with rose that I
don't think GPT has that and I think we
do need to be focusing on what it is
that makes us human and getting that
human understanding where I think the
disagreement is the difference is is
when you say the things we need to be
focused on in schools are not the things
we can easily automate I disagree with
that and the reason I disagree with that
is for a couple of reasons so first of
all we do want students to have those
Advanced skills the skills that
computers and AI don't have but what we
also know is in order to get those
Advanced skills there's no shortcut you
can't short circuit you have to go
through the basics so the students are
unfortunately going to have to spend
time grappling with the problems that AI
can solve immediately and that can be
automated immediately because they can't
get to the more advanced ones without
that and chess you mentioned chess chess
is a fascinating case study here for a
number of reasons because chess everyone
thought that deep blue and AI would kill
chess they thought the minute a computer
solve chess no one wants to play anymore
the reverse has happened there has been
a boom in chess people love chess but
when you teach a child to play chess now
do you say to them look don't bother
learning how the pieces move you need to
focus on strategy you know focus on the
things that AI the AI can't do of course
not you know for a student to get good
at chess they have to learn the pieces
first of all and the way that computers
have affected chess education is not by
telling students don't worry about the
basics don't worry about the things a
computer can do it's actually been by
developing some really interesting new
training uh patterns and so you know
things like chesskids.com you know
really interesting new ways of teaching
chess that do focus on the basics but do
it in a fun way that's the impact
technology has had on shares so we can't
be saying to students don't bother with
the things that computers can do that's
just gonna be you know it's going to
stop them getting the skills they do
need the second thing is
you know just because a computer can do
something doesn't mean there isn't value
for a human to do it so we didn't stop
teaching PE when the car got invented we
didn't stop teaching drawing when
cameras are invented if chat GPT can
read better than a lot of humans what
almost teaching reading because you get
a tremendous amount of value from
Reading you know you don't have to be as
good a reader as chat GPT to to get to
get value from it so I think the risk of
this is that we just end up defining
education completely you know
instrumentally and saying well you know
we've got every time chat you'd be
taking something new we're going to
change our curriculum and we shouldn't
teach kids that so I think we absolutely
agree with rose we've got to be focusing
on human understanding and what that is
and perhaps a positive of GPT will make
us think more about what that is but
that doesn't mean abandoning the basics
or the fundamentals
you said we did say we should automate
you should say we shouldn't be teach I
wrote it down you did say uh we
shouldn't be looking at the things we
can easily automate and I disagree with
that we like spirited um Witnesses
um Dawn had a question that um uh she
communicated via our system on the
implications for more examples you want
to just put that to the witnesses John
I'm just wondering
how do we level the playing field if
if chat gbt can write essays really well
does that mean we're going to go back to
having more intensified exams in exam
environments which is what we were
moving away from
I really hope not I think it does and I
think it should well let's let's hear
from Professor looking first you give
your exams are stressful they don't
produce accurate outcomes they are
outdated they're not part of the
learning process what I was trying to
say and I clearly didn't say it
clearly enough is that what we teach
children of the basics is fundamentally
important but it should be a tool to
help them gain the more advanced human
intelligence so yes you still have to do
it right so we should still take things
you can automate can we agree on that
yes otherwise it's difficult to um
reach the higher education and these
should not be the things we
assessments of Education because if we
assess the more advanced skills we will
in the process
both fundamentally just assess the
fundamentals
that it will come to you
seeing it in a slightly different way
because as I was saying earlier about
being able to track the learning process
you can track very nicely using
continual assessment exactly how much
somebody is learning of the very basic
things they do need to understand I
couldn't agree more
so we don't need those final exams once
we get our technology sorted and most
importantly once we get our data
infrastructure sorted within our
education system and actually the UK is
good in this respect and we can build on
what's there then there will be less
need for these
final exams so I think in the short term
I totally understand why Daisy is saying
look this is a way of stopping cheating
I get that but it should be a short-term
fix not the long-term goal the long-term
goal has to be to sit down and look at
what do we really want people to be able
to understand and do
through our education system
what's your response to you so I
absolutely think I think you know you're
absolutely right to make a distinction
between we have a final end goal and
then we can break that end goal down in
steps on the way and we can look at what
those steps on the way are and you can
do that for lots of different subjects
often the steps on the way don't look
like the end goal I think you need to
assess both I think you need to be
assessing the end goal um so those
Advanced skills we're talking about like
essay writing uh you know complex maths
problem solving complex science problem
solving you then also need to be looking
at what are the steps on the way they're
going to get you there because you can't
start assessing six-year-olds with those
complex Advanced problems right you've
got to be breaking down to the smaller
steps and that's actually what a lot of
the good AI systems you were talking
about do you know taking the complex
skills they're breaking them down
they're thinking how do we best teach
and assess those so that's what we do at
normal marketing the company I work for
we do big assessments of essays
um you know complex assessments of
advanced skills we also then break those
skills down into small steps and we
offer schools a multiple choice tool to
be able to design multiple choice
questions that will lead up to that end
goal so I definitely think you need to
do both I think you need to assess both
I think you need to pick the right
assessment and the right assessment
structure for each I think that the
coming of GPT does just mean that doing
any of those Assessments in uncontrolled
conditions just puts you in a situation
where you don't know if that work has
been completed by the student or not so
that's that's why I think you have to
have examples all right so let's take
some more questions from my colleagues
on on this theme it's important to say
that their inquiry is not into chat GPT
it's into AI generally and that's one
and only one um some particular tool but
uh erinville yeah sorry at risk of
continuing this a bit is the analogy not
with when pocket calculators came in in
the 80s and that basically changed
arithmetic fundamentally they originally
seen as cheating and then again and
obviously there was also an equity issue
when the cap came in because they cost a
lot of money in the first place and only
some students had them and they were
banned and then we actually realized it
was more sensible because everyone's
going to have access to computers and
cabinets when they're older we don't
need to do as much longer Vision or we
don't certainly only do slide rules we
do all of that if future is for people
are going to use tools like Japanese or
whatever comes after check GPD to do
creative work when they're an adult in
their adult lives
do we not need a system that Embraces
that but maybe not as as you said Daisy
not a primary school because we don't
know we don't let year five five year
old and six-year-olds play with
calculators to learn how to add up but
it's all about those those building
blocks this is it I think what we need
to think about is how do we get students
to have the advanced skills so I am
completely with you on and with rose on
the aim has to be the advanced skills
the question is how do we get there and
what we know is that it is really
important to have stored fluently in
long-term memory
um a body of facts and that is what
often allows you to do a lot of the
creative thinking and you know that
chess point I made you have to know how
the pieces move is the point and that's
why we've calculated we do still have
exams for Primary students where they're
Calculator free because there is a value
in getting to fluency and it's the same
as you know if you're reading a book you
can always look something up not just on
Google but in a dictionary you know
dictionaries existed for longer than
pocket calculators but we all know that
if you have to stop if you don't
understand 70 of the words in a text and
you have to stop all that time to look
up a word there's fluency of your
reading's gone
it's not just pocket calculators yeah
any reference source they're often
fantastic for people who have that kind
of fundamental Knowledge and Skills to
be able to access them but for the
students who don't have that that those
Basics they don't help them so I do
think a large part of primary and even
secondary schooling has to be about
making sure that students have those
fundamental basic skills and knowledge
that they need to be able to develop the
more advanced skills and to use all
these tools really effectively in lots
of ways it's meant that at secondary
level in particular I completely agree
about building blocks the maths is a
very different subject now at GCSE to
what it was at O Level you know and my
my question is do is it not the case
that that is how English and history and
other subjects will change as well I
don't know them to what extent math
season isn't a different subject I mean
you know I've got a copy of time of the
thing the first exams in England 1869
and you're right 1859 I think it is um
and you're right the math curriculum is
quite different
um I'm not sure all those reasons are to
do with pocket calculators there's a lot
more statistics in modern maths I'm
quite keen on that you know especially
given the organization I work for we use
a lot of stats but that's I don't think
that's necessarily come about that's
come about because you know we've seen
it as being more useful
um so what I think when you're saying it
does a curriculum need to change we need
to be thinking concretely about how
would you change it I still think in the
case of English as a former English
teacher the skills of reading and
writing are going to be phenomenally
important both advanced advanced level
in terms of the economic value they add
but also something we can often forget
when we talk about this just in terms of
the personal value they bring the
ability to read a novel or read a poem
and and enjoy that is very important too
so it feels to me that in terms of
English reading and writing always going
to be important they're fundamental
skills that underpin everything else we
know that in the UK as in you know some
other countries we have a we have a you
know unfortunately a number of students
who don't have the literacy skills they
need to engage in the modern world so it
feels to me those are all really
important things that we need to focus
on we can't get distracted by thinking
we can just forget about the basics and
you know because chat GPT will do that
and we can just focus on the on the
higher level stuff you have to go
through the basics to get to that higher
level it's looking
such an interesting question and it's a
very complicated answer actually because
absolutely literacy and numeracy
fundamental have to have those in there
but the calculator issue is an
interesting one because the calculator
isn't intelligent
and what we're talking about here is
something much more sophisticated
now if I look at a high level skill say
something like metacognition we know
that people with sophisticated
metacognition do better they do better
in the world of work they do better in
their learning outcomes we know that
now
to teach metacognition you can't do it
in a vacuum you have to teach it within
a subject area so that speaks to Daisy's
point about the need for subject areas
we also know that it's different at
primary school because it because it's a
developmental aspect so the way that you
would go about teaching metacognition
through a subject area maybe science
maybe English whatever is different in a
primary school to a secondary school
the point I'm making is that by focusing
on the metacognition rather than the
subject and seeing the subject
taking literacy and numeracy is Givens
we have to have those in high quality
versions of those and seeing Alters the
way that you teach and it Alters the way
that you assess
and that's what's important here it's
not that I'm saying we don't need those
basic things it's just that we need them
in a different way
because we want to have the situation
where we continue to be
the most intelligent form of
intelligence and there's a very
important issue here that I think has to
be grasped and that is the risk of
offloading
now our brains are naturally lazy
yeah and therefore we will of course as
is being shown at the moment with church
GPT if something else can do something
for us we're highly likely to offload oh
I don't like doing this it's making me
think hard there's this system to do
this we do not want that to happen
now in order for us to be productive
it could be effective to offload certain
things
the most important thing we need to
decide is what are the things we are
happy to offload and what are the things
we are not happy to offload
and we need to consciously Design
Systems that recognize that we will want
to offload fight against ourselves
exactly so we need to work out and
that's where the AI with link Beyond
chat GPT can be super helpful because as
I was saying to your colleague we are
now getting very good
at
taking data signals and learning about
the process that a learner is going
through and when I was a teacher in
further education teaching learn adults
with special needs oh I would have loved
to have known what was going on I could
have been so much better than I was now
if we do that you can't cheat with that
you can't cheat with that that's your
data and formative assessment using AI
is a way that we can really move forward
with assessment where it's less
stressful it's in the background it
can't we can't cheat with it and we can
use the ion there's another ethical
implications of that I'm not saying it's
easy but it's possible and it's not a
long way off so we need to recognize
that this stuff is coming and we can use
it and it will hit that point of
equality if we design it in the right
way because of the um the human rather
than machine interactions this morning
we're running over time so I'm gonna
have to ask my colleagues to be brief in
their questions and our Witnesses I'll
be very thank you chair
um could I just ask all Witnesses in
this inquiry have been reluctant to
answer this question but 10 years time
do you think education will look
fundamentally different as a result of
AI or is it just going to be an
incremental Improvement um briefly first
professor luckin and then absolutely it
will fundamentally no question it will
look fundamentally different it's how it
will look fundally mentally fundally
mentally fundamentally different and so
a few years ago I said that I could see
the dystopian and I could see my
optimistic version that I want dystopian
version is because it's cheap we will we
could have a horrible future where we
have
most of the population being educated by
AI teaching machines with some minders
and a bit of you know looking after
because it's cheap and we can track what
people are learning etc etc and then
we'll have people who can afford it
having the rich human interactions
integrated with the AI all of the good
stuff that's horrible
but we are at risk of that happening
what we can do but we really do have to
make the decisions now and we do
have to get over the fact that we've
invested a huge amount of energy in
designing something that's beautifully
designed our current curriculum it's
really beautifully designed but it has
to change because the world is changing
and if we want the optimistic version
when we go back to the reason we had
exams in the first place where we go
back to wanting to bring about equality
we have to look
that the situation differently
interested
um so I agree about this dystopian
vision and I think that's the thing that
a lot of people with AI education worry
about is is it just going to be kids
sitting in front of screens with eye
trackers and uh kind of you know rewards
for if they get certain questions right
and I agree you don't want that but I'm
fairly optimistic on that because I
think not only did you know does that
sound not sound very nice I don't think
people want that and I don't think kids
want it I think you saw in the pandemic
if that was going to happen it would
have happened and it didn't because
people want what was you know people
wanted to get back to school sure So
when you say what will education look
like in 10 years
um I actually think this depends on what
how you define look I actually think it
could look quite similar in that I think
children may I I think the physical
aspect of schools is important and the
the you know the physical Place matters
so I think there's a way in which
schools might look very similar to
schools today but I think that the what
goes on around them and how everything
works around them will have you know
could have been transformed and the
analogy I often like to use is maybe if
you're sitting down to eat dinner but in
lots of ways there's aspects of that are
very similar to sitting down to eat
dinner maybe 100 years ago but the food
on your plate and everything around that
has been completely transformed by
technology and so that might be an
analogy that things might look the same
but the nature of what's going on there
yeah the technology in all kinds of ways
has the potential to make to transform
after better
thank you very much Aaron and uh finally
Tom Butler sure um just a quick question
around a difficult subject of bias
um where do the AI tools developed by
edtech firms Source their data
depends on the AI company sorry that's
not meant to be a physician facetious
answer but it's a really good question
and it's a question that anybody who's
thinking about buying any of those
systems should be asking where is your
data coming from what are you doing with
that data explain it to me in a way that
I understand and don't tell me it's
commercially sensitive and you can't
tell me because that's rubbish you can
because I think that's a really
important question we have to we have to
know where the data is coming from how
reliable it is how representative it's
it is of the population who's going to
be using that system how much it's
updated and the big point that Daisy
made earlier about not knowing what
openai are doing with the data that they
have we know nothing about what they're
doing with the data they're collecting
every time anybody types anything into
it and so again the same question to
what you're asking what happens to the
data that is putting in being put into
these systems does it add to the pool of
data from which the system learns and in
which case are we increasing the bias
because of the people who are using it
do you see what I mean so it's a it's a
really really important question and we
have to empower people
to ask that question and know how to ask
that question which incidentally The
Institute for ethical Ai and education
that produced a reporter a couple of
years ago did try and help Educators
understand the questions to ask when
procuring Ai and some of that was around
data because you're right it's really
important
yeah that's right and it's a distinction
I think a lot of the narrow AI sort of
um applications they'll be coming up
with their own sets of training data for
whatever that's for and um you know even
yeah so often they'll be using human
judgments that they've gathered
previously
um to help predict you know make the
judgments for for the model so that
would be
um be that I think
you're right you know the issue with
gpts as I said earlier we don't know
what it's been trained on and that's a
huge issue for working anything out to
do with with bias a lot of the narrow AI
models they might not be completely
transparent there's an element of
opacity to all of this but you will be
able to at least see you should be able
to see kind of what they've been trained
on and therefore kind of how they're
making their decisions so definitely
come back to what I said before one of
the key things about regulation probably
is going to be the transparency of the
training data thank you
and Tracy Crouch very finely very quick
question and my apologies for being late
that's been fascinating session
Professor luck you said
um either we need to be or we want to be
the most intelligent form of
intelligence which is a really really
interesting uh phrase do you think we
can be I do yes but I think we have to
really make the right decisions and you
know the brand the brain is amazing this
there's so much of it that we're
learning about now and
so far beyond what AI can do every time
we think we've got closer to artificial
general intelligence there will be some
aspect of what we can do people go oh oh
yeah there's that too so I do think we
can but what I think is interesting is
that in a lot of the ways that
regulators and indeed large
organizations who are making an awful
lot of money out of AI talk about the
situation is don't worry we'll have a
human human in the loop we'll have a
human in the loop it'll all be all right
because there'll be a human in the loop
what if that human doesn't understand AI
you know because if we don't do the
helping reason to get to the place where
they can be the useful human in the leap
they're not actually that useful sorry I
hope that's helpful but it's very
helpful I request not to be that human
yes
thank you I kind of just wanted to ask
you a quick question
chair is indulging me the final question
I'm just wondering I mean we're talking
a lot about where we are here in the UK
and just want another interesting
aspects of AI been used in education in
other countries where should we be
looking to get a good example or a bad
example
look at China for about
it
um that's fairly obvious but it's scary
um
but there's a lot to be learned from
that in all fairness
obviously though the country in the
world that's doing the greatest amount
of surveillance and it's very Advanced
they know ever such a lot about their
population and you know over time we'll
be able to track exactly who knows what
where how well precisely what they're
doing with it Etc it's not a way we want
to go obviously
I think we need to look at that and
learn how
to go about it but also to learn
the power that data can bring with it
I think we need to look at a much more
conservative Way Forward now the US is
very good at investing
in Ai and education in a way that that
we are not now we are good at AI in the
UK we're certainly you know the top five
in terms of sophisticated understanding
science development of AI systems so I
think the US is good in terms of the
amount it investors in it but I think
there are other countries much smaller
countries in Scandinavia
um and in parts of Eastern Europe where
they are taking a step back and really
thinking about how to
help everybody get an understanding of
AI I loved the finish one percent
project Let's help one percent of the
population to understand Ai and then
they can help another one percent to
understand AI if that had been here we
probably would have gone oh let's have
69 of the population completely
impossible one percent so achievable
yeah I would say I've just returned um
for a visit to Australia and they've got
an organization for example yeah the um
they've just set up a federal
organization
um the Australian education for research
for research and that's I think they're
doing some interesting things yeah
they're Federal they're a federal group
they can look across the states they've
got a bit of a bigger remit and they've
also got links with other government
departments and I think it's like you
know having that conversation with other
it's not just an education issue
um thinking about in other areas and yes
I think I think they're doing some some
interesting things and thinking about
this in some interesting ways too thank
you thank you very much just a final
question for me I'm intrigued your
company is called No More marking um uh
final final
why is it called No More marking because
in in assessment terms the technical
assessment meaning of marking is
applying a number to a piece of work
and what we do this is does not involve
AI what we do is we use an approach
called comparative judgment it's human
judgment but it's human comparative
judgment that the human will read the
writing but instead of applying a mark
to one piece of writing they will read
two pieces comparative judgment and they
will say which is the better piece of
writing and they make a series of
decisions like that so at no stage are
they ever applying a mock to a piece of
writing but then when the results when
all the decisions are crunched together
all of the pieces of writing will be
allocated Marx satisfied my curiosity
admirably uh can I thank uh
that was a fascinating session and
you've exposed a lot of the the debates
that we have in here so we're very
grateful can I um an apology is very 10
minutes later invite our next panel of
witnesses to join us at the table and
I'm pleased to introduce them they are
Dr Matthew Glanville Dr lanville is the
head of assessment principles and
practice at the international
Baccalaureate the IB which provides
education programs to nearly 2 million
students worldwide and Dr Glanville is a
former maths teacher joined the IB in
prior to that had Herald roles at
offqual the qualifications exams and
assessments regulator and he has a PHD
in mathematics welcome Dr lanville and
general Kenyon Mr Kenyon is a science
teacher and is the community cohesion
lead at Dormers Wells High School in
Seoul in London he has a website in
question which covers content related to
but outside the national curriculum to
help enrich lessons very grateful to
both of you for coming today perhaps I
could just start with a very brief
question to Dr Glanville give even the
publication of the white paper today
that places its emphasis on existing
Regulators rather than a new regulator
as someone that was formally in off-call
does that does that seem sensible to you
or would you uh does your experience
lead you to favor another Direction in
other words a specialist regulator
um I think it's really important that
people who have a fundamental
understanding of education then look at
what artificial intelligence means in
that context rather than the other way
around so I'm definitely favor of the
existing expert Regulators feeding into
how it works by an education thank you
that's very clear and very helpful
perhaps I consult with the question to
Mr Kenyan and thank you for taking time
away from your students today I hope
they'll they'll forgive uh the uh of our
claim on on you but I'm very we're all
very interested to know how uh how you
as a teacher use AI in your classroom
with your students in particular with um
it's in particular with research with
making resources that's mainly how I use
it because main the largest part of
education and teachings of a lot of time
is made in making them resources so I
just try to find ways in where I can
shorten the time that it takes me to
make something so sometimes I know what
I want to make and I know how I want to
make it but it's getting that first step
and so for example with a wagon so what
a good one looks like or a wobble what a
bad one looks like which would be an
answer to an essay question and then
from that essay question it would
generate an answer and then they would
critique it say this was what good about
it this is what's bad about it I can
also make it you um put in spelling
mistakes so I'll put in I'll say put
five spelling mistakes in there and then
the pupils have to go through and
highlight the spelling mistakes you use
the word webble yeah that is I'm very
familiar to you but not I'm afraid to uh
to me and perhaps some other members so
just so what a bad one looks like what a
bad one looks like yeah so it's an essay
that is not very good so then the pupils
then have to critique what what is good
about it and chat it the chat GPT is
actually really good at making a bad
version of something and it can also
make a really good version of something
that then the kids can then
um that's a waggle is it that's a waggle
yeah
I see okay well we've got some important
piece of learning that we've uh We've
made
um so um so you apply that now do you do
it is this a kind of person personal
thing do you do it does your school do
it in a structured way
um how does it we have a we centralize
our lessons in science
um where we were all although all the
different topics we divvied out and then
we were all responsible for the topics
that we made and then all of them
resources are made as a department and
we share them all so when I was making
mine and chat GPT came onto the scene I
just went oh maybe I can use this and
then I used it to make mine so some of
my resources for Key Stage 3 and then
the personal ones that I have for Key
Stage Four and key stage five and I've
I've made them personally it's not
necessarily something the school is
using but it is something that
individual teachers are using in order
to speed up a process I see and you've
got this um in question website is that
is that sort of promoting what you're
doing in your practice uh more widely or
making it available more widely it's
just making it available and
highlighting it so it's a practice
called Hinterland which is the stuff
that's not on the curriculum that can
sometimes make the curriculum a little
bit more interesting and so just stories
from a wide range of fields
um that are just a little addition a
little add-on that can sometimes make a
subject that's quite dull or not that
interesting to where people just make it
a little bit more interesting and so
then I've written some odd some articles
on there that wouldn't potentially be
interesting for another teacher to use
and they're mentioned in the classroom
and apply context or real world
applications so some of the designs that
we talk about and then I also go through
how you can use it in a lesson as well
so okay that's very helpful uh Patrick's
question to Dr Lambert before I turn to
my colleagues um so the the IB
um hit the headlines a few weeks ago um
in making a statement that you won't ban
the organization won't ban the use of
tools like chat GPT
um in for the the IB exam could you just
explain uh the rationale I would explain
what that means in practice and and why
you you've come to that decision
excellent so the ib's approach is that
students who use passages of text or
other things generated by artificial
intelligence must reference that in the
same way as they would reference any
other material they've taken from a
different source and that means that
they need to put it in quotation marks
say after the part this is how this is
what I've used is where it's come from
and then included in the bibliography
what system they use and also what
prompts they use to generate it and the
principle here is that we're trying to
make sure that students are transparent
about what is the old work that they've
produced and what they have referred
back from somewhere else whether it's
artificial intelligence system or
whether it's from another source
altogether
um this was say published on the the
27th and then on the 16th of March we
followed that up with a new academic
Integrity policy which sets out a whole
Annex dedicated to the use of artificial
intelligence in this context I see so
and this is for assignments that are
outside the exam room yes yes this is
really for the the coursework elements
that was spoken about earlier obviously
with exams themselves the students
wouldn't have access to the technology
to do this but we do have coursework
that camps towards the final grade I
understand so um so your requirement is
that if if AI is used
um then you have to kind of reference it
and and cite it we heard you probably
you're sitting for the previous session
you'll have heard that it's very
difficult to detect
um whether it has indeed been used so
how what what is your thought process
around detecting things where people
haven't made the the citation that you
if you say you require this is where the
IB approach to that coursework is really
helpful because we've always required
that teachers are alongside the students
during the process of writing their
coursework so they need to have meetings
with them as they're starting to think
about what the coursework is and then
working with them during it and looking
at early drafts to the final place and
in that context teachers are able to
recognize when suddenly a whole pile of
work that the student hadn't previously
even thought about appears and can have
those conversations with the student
about where did that come from what does
that mean and this is actually exactly
the same approach we use with essays
brought off the internet that teachers
can recognize when suddenly a student
goes from having no understanding to
some understanding are they required do
you have kind of rules that they sign up
to to undertake to yeah to spot that and
intervene yes we have clear instructions
on how teachers should support students
during their coursework and teachers are
expected to sign declaration that's to
the best of their knowledge this is this
is the student's own work and that again
has been in place for multiple years in
the IB and what has been your experience
of as it were policing that obviously
there's there's pressure on schools
there's on students to get good exam
results
how have you found that you often
have to as a workout audit the the the
the performance of teachers in this and
the uh the practice of teachers in this
um what we found is that teachers are
very good at spotting where there's a
step change in their students learning
that seems odd and very very much so
being able to say yeah there's something
odd going on here we have on occasions
needed to be very supportive of our
teachers saying that is a clear
responsibility because obviously parents
and students can put a lot of pressure
on to teachers to say well come on look
the other way but we're lucky that we've
got a a very committed group of teachers
who are prepared to stand up and say
actually no it isn't and the IB can then
step in to support the teachers and the
schools when they say these things but
do you kind of sample particular
scripts or contributions and and
interrogate them and go back and look at
the history of the teachers intervention
yes we do both of those we have when we
have our school inspection visits that's
part of what we look at and also we've
taken the sample of all coursework
anyway and review it and interrogate it
now that is a very powerful tool with
plagiarism but as the previous Witnesses
said we don't think that's going to be
the right tool to use for tests for
checking this sort of artificial
intelligence because it's not going to
be able to detected the same way as a
high quality sa Mill sa can't be
detected because it's a unique piece of
work and we don't know the student
anything like the teachers know students
so that's where the the best opportunity
for identifying this comes from I see I
should just ask
do you do you teach the IB in your
schools
and is there is there an opportunity for
people to to use
AI tools like um chat gbt in coursework
for the exams that you teach so I
specifically teach science so it doesn't
have we're 100 exams uh but then there
is in year 12 the CPAC element which is
the practicals that we do uh so what
they all have to produce a write-up so
there is an opportunity for them to
therefore use AI in order to answer
their questions or to write an entire
report about an experiment that they've
done and however I don't actually think
it poses that much of an issue because
all these exams these cpacs have done
hundreds of times by hundreds of
different students and there are a
wealth of resources already online that
the kids can already copy and paste and
slightly edit slightly so
they can use AI to help them answer
their question but it will probably just
be easier for them to use a resource
that's already been made so what what I
do as a teacher and what a lot of us do
is when we look at the CPAC write-ups is
we say is what does did they do this in
in the Practical session uh is the data
that they got the data that they got in
the Practical session are the
conclusions ones that we've spoken about
or ones that they that would pop up do
they fit where they are in the
curriculum because are they mentioning
stuff that's in topic six or seven in
topic four so we take all of that
information in when we look at their
what the work that they've given us it's
a similar process there is there is
strong personal teacher kind of scrutiny
of of what is being said so when we talk
about the dystopian opportunities where
the kids look at the screen Etc
um the problem with that with AI is in
order for us to detect whether a pupil
has cheated or used AI when they're
giving coursework for example the only
way that we're actually really good at
doing that is the relationships that we
have with the pupils over time and the
understanding of where they are in the
curriculum so if you took out the human
element then that makes it impossible to
detect whether a people has cheated so
therefore a human element is is needed
because it's the only way that we could
figure out whether people has used an AI
or not okay that's very interesting
there's a brief supplementary from Aaron
Bell that I'm going to go Steven Metcalf
thank you chair there's team Dr glamor
just
it's appreciate the difficulty you're in
obviously with chat GPT and all of uses
but if your method so far is basically
well the pupil is obviously Advanced far
beyond what we'd expect or they've done
it too quickly surely a chat kpt can
produce an essay in the style of the
previous essays of that student I mean
that's just a matter of laziness rather
than trying to get a better grade
I mean is there not a real fundamental
concern for a continuous assessment and
coursework that we heard in the first
session that it's just not going to be
possible if once people start using
these tools in a in quotes Smart Way
um I'd absolutely agree with you that
there's a real Challenge and as my
colleague here has indicated I do think
the teachers are able to understand what
their students are capable of doing
um and I think it's a very interesting
question that if they're using
artificial intelligence to create what
they could have created themselves does
that then become an assessment issue or
does that be then kind of a behavioral
issue because they'll get the same
outcome
um more generally yes I think it raises
some really challenging questions about
how we do assessment outside of a
tightly controlled but I personally
believe in the IB I think the IB
believes that there are some skills that
really aren't best to test in an exam
context and that's the problem there
what is it we value you've got a flavor
of that earlier what is it we think is
important and what's the best way to
assess that and it may well be that some
of those
we can't do meaningfully in an exam
context and therefore it's better to
assess them in the best situations we
can get rather than not assess them in
their more secure system and that's the
tension that we deal with every single
day thank you
I thank you very Stephen mcgoth and
Rebecca Long Bailey thank you chair
excuse me
um
experience how many
minutes you think
firstly are aware that AI is available
to help them secondly are using it and
how do we keep track of that I suppose
the third part right
um the the third part is the bit that I
think would require actively going out
there and doing high quality research
which isn't being done at the moment
my impression is that we've been talking
a lot with our teachers through multiple
different routes seminars
planned conversations to explain
webinars about how assessment Works uh
conferences and probably because of the
statement most of our teachers are now
aware and starting to think about it and
they are from they're giving us feedback
that their students are also aware of
sort of artificial intelligence so I I
think in the short term there will be a
a lot of students who understand and
know about it
um I think the challenge we've got is
how do we turn that knowledge into
ethical and safe use rather than using
it in the sort of shortcuts which has
been described earlier yeah but that's
just within the IBS just within the IBC
I haven't had contact with them outside
would you care to speculate or should we
ask Joel if he has any insights I think
I'm gonna have to pass an impossible
question to you so you don't know either
it's kind of one of them you I don't
think you'll ever know I don't think
you'll ever know the number of people
that are using it I don't they are using
it there's no two ways about it some of
them will say that they use it or will
say that they've looked at it or made it
try to do something but they'll never I
don't think they'll ever admit to saying
oh I use it doesn't make this essay
because that's just not going to happen
so therefore trying to collect data on
trying to find out how many people are
using it isn't even impossible because
it's just a questionnaire and you could
just take no I don't know I can use it
um but so from just your sort of local
personal experience students you're
interacting with are aware of its
existence and they're using it
you possibly exactly so but you don't
really know in what ways and no so in
terms of that homework and stuff we use
a we use an online system called educate
that does our homework for us and I know
a lot of other departments do that as
well but in one's where we're asking
them to do essays and stuff like that
then in English for example I can
imagine it's going to be quite difficult
for them to get anything useful out of
their um the feedback giving feedback
for their homework because we do not
know if they've used
um a system or not so it would be really
difficult this isn't I mean in the area
that I was going to question about just
in terms of this explosion of AI and
obviously it's now turning into a sort
of an arms race or a battle between you
as Educators and teachers and big Tech
Giants you know helping students combat
you sounds like some sort of bizarre
video game do you think there is any
responsibility on the tech companies
themselves to potentially embed data
within so you can't just copy and paste
an essay you've written that actually
it's not feasible you'd have to retype
it in which case you might have learned
something
um I think I'd like to rephrase you
initial premise not to be a battle
between
um artificial intelligence is going to
become part of our everyday lives I
think that question of do we get
dystopian do we get a beautiful future
is important and what we really need to
do is to make sure that we support our
students in understanding what what
ethical and what useful approaches are
um I do think that I would be grateful
to the tech companies if they could do
more to try and embed things but I'm
also realistic that that's not a silver
bullet that'll address all of it there
will be other systems that don't have
that set up so even if the big ones act
responsibly there'll be others that
still pose the same challenge so let's
let's address the the real issue and not
try and fight against something that's
going to become part of I think everyday
life in the not too distant future I am
just going to Echo that one it's going
to happen you can you could regulate it
and say that you can't put in larger
volumes of text and ask them to do it
but there will be another one using a
VPN to access in a foreign country that
doesn't have that regulation in place
and they will just be able to use it you
could ask certain companies to limit the
amount of information it can give in or
how much it can output but again there
will be another company that will just
not do that you have got the big ones
like open AI Google have just released
Bard they are they are the big ones but
it's the smaller ones that you will near
on find impossible to regulate so
instead of trying to fix it with
regulation try
try to look at what is the outcome and
how we work with them outcomes rather
than trying to over awkwardly change
everything okay no it's very helpful
thank you
um so I suppose what that highlights is
that this is a powerful tool it's here
to stay
AI is actually you know we interact with
AI every single day of Our Lives now on
our phones and
decisions made on our behalf
some of those decisions are very serious
some of them are not and so therefore we
judge the risk associated with
individual artificial intelligences
where would you place
AI in education on that sliding scale of
risk is this something we've really you
know is it a big issue that we've got to
get our heads around
or is this just an interesting Sideshow
that teachers educators will work out
how to deal with
I think because
I believe that it's going to become part
of our everyday lives it's a really
important thing because otherwise we're
going to end up with an education system
that prepares students for yesterday's
issues not tomorrow's issues and that's
that's not true of officers that's true
of all of us so I think it's something
we really should be thinking about right
now and so it's quite high up that that
list
where I am less cons not less concerned
but I think that with working with our
teachers it doesn't need to be the
showstopper to assessment it presents
some real challenges or make us really
rethink how we assess and what do we
assess and that's a really important
thing but I I think really about
understanding the impact he's going to
make on the world so how do we need to
teach our students to work within this
new paradigm that's what's really
important here and that's a big
challenge that we need to address sooner
rather than later and we'll just where
we're talking about AI
changing the face of Education I don't
necessarily believe it's going to be a
massive Silver Bullet will have massive
ramifications for how we teach I do I
agree with Daisy from before education
will probably just look the same I don't
think it will make large changes but one
of the things that we do need to look at
is
is again the same issue that was raised
before where is it getting its
information from so if you're use if
you're a pupil who is being asked to
critically evaluate something and you
want your little starting base which is
what a lot of people use tragedy GPT for
where's my starting point and it puts
you with a starting point with a heavy
bias then that that changes the entire
way that you write the rest of your
essay and one we do need to know where
they're getting their information from
chat GPT for example where we gave you
your false profile and is using data
that's two years old Googles is using
data that is immediately on the internet
and we already know the level of
misinformation on the internet already
and the problem is is that people's
using this AI in the classroom or using
this AI to answer questions from a
homework for example it may
inadvertently introduce them to their
misconceptions and and then biases but
in terms of the risk to people's
education to students education is the
the emergence of these Technologies is
so just in your view is it low risk
medium risk high risk so
if so for my subject in particular I
think it's relatively low risk mainly
because of the things I teach so and the
way it's assessed so because it's
assessed in an exam they haven't got
access to any of this and then the the
assessments that I do in lesson and the
questioning I do in lesson they don't
have access to them either I imagine in
subjects where they use coursework based
and will be significantly more impacted
so for my subject I think it's
relatively low but in ones with
coursework I can imagine that's
relatively High brilliant and Final
it is going to have a far bigger impact
in some of the coursework areas it's not
a new challenge we've always had the sa
Mills and everything else but what it
does do is bring it to a
far larger part of the community
um I think it is I probably put it in
the medium risk category
excellent thank you both thousands of
the exam questions thank you very much
for being uh Stephen uh Rebecca Long
Bailey and I'm Tracy Crouch thank you
we've spent quite a lot of time
discussing the challenges of AI in
education but what guidance or support
would you like to see from the
government and Regulators on the use of
AI and education starting with Matthew
um
I think right the IB obviously is an
international organization and therefore
we believe that we've actually got that
obligation to support our teachers and
our students in understanding that and
whilst I would be delighted to
understand what the feedback from the
government is and the ideas from
government and Regulators off-call we
also need to be doing that
internationally so we get the best
possible thing I do think it's really
important we get information from
somewhere to our teachers and our
students soon and the feedback I'm
getting from a lot of our teachers is
what's working well
we've heard about this how should we use
it in our classrooms how can you share
with us good examples and the IB is is
trying to do that we we have a a system
called IB exchange where teachers can
exchange ideas about what they're going
on and artificial intelligence has been
a big part of that in recent years but I
think we really need to be taking the
good examples we've got and sharing
those and soon as rather than later
are there any particular countries
obviously you work internationally where
you think they've got the support and
regulation right on this so far
I don't think there's any particular
country around the world which we are
using as our as our Benchmark a lot of
countries are thinking about this a lot
of countries having some very sensible
ideas about it and it's about taking all
of those together and bringing them into
into one place
thank you and Joel um the initial
question to you what regulation and
support would you like to see from
government so it's mainly advice so
and sign posters to what you can
actually use it for I don't think it can
be regulated away and I think if you can
regulate it so much that it will be
unregulatable and it just won't work in
practice in terms of for teachers
um the the government do make their
teacher workload surveys and the teacher
workload guidance I do think that the AI
should be part of the teacher workflow
guidance in a way that the two that
people can use it in order to reduce the
level of workload and in terms for
students and just highlighting to them
the issues so for example we have the
jcq who regulate exams and and have how
the exams happen and they use all of the
information they get from the different
exam boards maybe we should use that
information to say Well when you're
looking at coursework based these are
the things that you should look out for
um could we could the government work
with organizations to maybe make a
better plagiarism Checker and that may
or may not be impossible but
I think the guidance needs to be
how do how can you use it to reduce your
workload and what are the ways that we
should understand how pupils are using
it so to signpost to the issues and how
to deal with them issues and best
practice when speaking with other
Educators to try and find out how to
limit the impact of housing skills thank
you and are there any specific skills
that you think students might need in
the future in education as a result of
ai's growth what sort of things should
Educators be trying to teach their
students at this time so
I have a I have a particular issue when
we talk about the the new skills for the
future type thing
um because they're all of the skills
that they've developed in the future
we're not taught in schools I do think
it's a baseline a baseline foundational
knowledge that needs to be focused on do
I think AI forms a baseline fundamental
knowledge no it's a tool it's not a
piece of knowledge I don't necessarily
believe that the kids need to know how
it works or what it does because they
can figure that out quite quickly they
don't know how a calculator works but
they can use a calculator I don't think
this needs to be anything prescribed on
the curriculum I don't necessarily
believe it should be anything taught or
it just needs to be mentioned in lessons
as a tool that you can use if you wish
to use it
um because the pupils are going to use
it but maybe we need to think about how
it's the best way that then pupils can
use it and that's how it should be fed
in it should just be used as when we
mention calculators this is a tool that
you can use it is incredibly powerful
but it is a tool that you can use to
make your life easier or to make writing
something a little bit easier but do I
think it's going do I think it should be
tall no not really
the really important one here is
understanding of bias the difference
between
getting something up on Google and
getting it up with an artificial
intelligence engine it sounds very
authoritative and it's not and all the
previous conversations about the bias
the inherent issues around what source
material it learned from to produce this
that's the real bit that is absolutely
critical and then that feeds into the
principles of being able to understand
and listen to other people's arguments
and appreciate there are different
points of view all all of which is
absolutely critical to an education
obviously part of what my organization
strongly believes so that's the real big
key one for me they need to learn not to
take it at face value but to interrogate
it to think about it to look at it and
they those are skills that they should
apply to any piece of information they
get from anywhere else so it's not a new
skill but it's just more important now
because there isn't any filter to it and
that's that's something you need to be
aware of can I just add into that again
and they do need to be aware of this but
it it's just now a new additional one
that they need to be aware of because
they've we've been using the internet
for years people's pupils have been
using them and they've they need to
learn that bias from the website so they
get their information from and this is
just another one of them things that we
as teachers need to teach pupils to
understand bias this is just another one
of them things that we add into that mix
thank you thank you very much indeed
Rebecca Tracy Crouch and then George
Oliver from the bias
and we're just having a conversation
about the bitterness that some of us
still feel decades on from our friends
copying essays days before the internet
exists and getting better grades than us
because they had always got better
grades now so how do you as teachers
also sort of kind of
respond to the bias that might have been
generated in what's being given to you
in terms of you you'll have your own
sort of kind of bias towards what a
student is is presenting because that
student's always given something that's
good so how do you remove that to sense
check what whether it's been AI
generated or not okay I I think what
you're talking about there is how do we
make sure that teachers don't aren't
biased and don't stereotype students
um if that's the case you're actually
right that's one of the real key skills
of being a good teacher to be able to
recognize your own personal biases and
the baggage you bring to situation and
and then work to remove it and that's
part of teacher training I mean that
that's a lot a long way from
conversations about artificial
intelligence but it's absolutely
critical that you if you've got teachers
who bring their bias and impose their
views on their students we need to deal
that with teach trading no matter
whether it's IB teacher training or UK
or anywhere else I mean you'll be better
place to respond I suspect and so I
don't necessarily don't necessarily be
blood in polished but in terms of
we all have a bias the bias is the
teachers have a bias and we are when we
do our training we're taught how to live
try to eliminate that bias or try to or
try to be the devil's advocate in here
in every situation so when the pupils
talk about like for example creationism
when I teach Evolution
um do I have a bias of course I have a
bias um both and people who are
religious would have a bias so what we
do is we then form uh an argument
between the two we look at the pros and
the cons from both situations and then
we discuss that at a classroom so they
understand the biases and it's just a
skill that teachers have and when you
mention about the
the copy and the essay from the other
person if I was to have a student that
just appeared in my lesson one day and
they gave me an essay
is mate which are GPT it would probably
get a good Mark and I probably wouldn't
suspect it but what we do as teachers is
we we for some cases were with them for
years so for year 12 students in year 13
students sometimes we've seen them over
seven years and we meet them multiple
times and we have all of other teachers
in the same Department who understand
them pupils as well and what we have in
the classroom is we have conversations
where we go you have them in year 11 is
this the type of work that you'd expect
from them and then it's a yes or a no
and then when it's a no that's seemingly
come out of nowhere there's been a
massive jump in just a year then that's
when we look at it and we go where did
you get this information from is this
plagiarized from someone have you got it
from somewhere and they're just the
conversations that we need to have and
you say about when they cop they copy
off uh off cut off you like change the
words and stuff like that again we're
really good at noticing we can always
tell when they follow the same theme or
this the same understanding we the
teachers are taught and teachers
understand that
kids are going to do it so you need to
be learning how to spot it well I mean
what I'm just sort of kind of trying to
suggest is say Dawn is a a gray student
doesn't surprise me and uh I'm a c grade
student which wouldn't surprise any of
my previous teachers
um
we've both used AI
to come up with very similar essays okay
Thorns is considered a grade because
Thorns has always been a grade but mine
despite the fact that we've used exactly
the same level of AI to generate the
same answers in the same format
you're saying that I would also get an A
because Dawn's got an A or would you
sort of kind of suggest that even though
we've used the same tools that I would
still get
is you can test for people's
understanding by what question they ask
so did you ask chat GPT the right
question did you ask the AI the right
question and it would be the difference
in the level of knowledge between
YouTube for example where we where the
outcome would be different the output
from Google from the AI would be
different based on the information that
you give it to begin with and then
maybe that a grade student would be able
to notice where it's a little bit too
advanced or it's mentioning something
that I don't know and therefore able to
edit it whereas the C grade student may
say I'll say C grade where they may not
be able to go hmm that's too advanced
for me because they don't know where the
level of Advance stops because they're
not there yet there is a bias of course
there is where you've been getting A's
all of the time
I want to give you another a you've been
getting C's all of the time maybe you've
just made a good essay and but it's a
conversation I'm not just going to give
you it back with no feedback and and
blank it off I'll say this is a good
essay but I am also concerned as to
where you've got your information from
so in in a cold cut scenario where we
mark it and give it them and that's it
then yes that can happen but we Mark
with conversations and feedback to help
build the students understanding as to
why they've got that Mark and then also
we then find out whether or not you've
cheated I think this is putting
additional pressure on the teaching
profession as a consequence of that in
terms of fact checking and everything
else will do it will do and if that is
one thing that the government does need
some guidance on is how do we do it in
the best way possible that doesn't
increase the amount of workloads I do
think it doesn't that much now but I do
think it will in the future sorry I will
let you come back but I just wanted to
give you an example actually of the new
Google AI function I don't know why but
a friend put into it is Tracy Crouch a
good person
um and uh you would please know that
they can't make moral judgments for
themselves but
um it rather interestingly it says she
has also been criticized for her support
of fixed odds betting terminals which is
the complete offer said given I've
resigned from government over fixed I
was playing terminals now that means
that actually this uh AI you talked
about misinformation on the internet has
actually gone on to the wrong piece of
information now you as a teacher say for
whatever reason you were asking your
class to do an essay or me
um uh that you now have to go back and
and this this is where the subject
knowledge is incredibly important so I
know my curriculum there will be
there'll be part of my curriculum that I
don't know as well as others uh but I
know my curriculum and teachers know
their curriculum and as as time goes on
when you start you don't know that much
of it you really know what you've got
from your degree and then as you've been
teaching it for a few years you start to
learn more and then you find out what
their misconceptions are
um so again that's a test of subject
knowledge if I was a politics teacher
who was just talking about you for
example then I would if I was teaching
you and how what you've been doing then
I'd know and I'd read and I'd understand
before I taught it so then I'd instantly
be able to pick up the misconception if
I'm teaching science for example and I
ask them structure of the AF and they
mix up all of the order I can instantly
figure out that they've missed up all of
the order because I'm good I have good
subject knowledge and I think that's one
thing that is important in order to help
combat this AI teachers need good
subject knowledge and that that again
should is is part of the teacher
standards and but I do think it does
need to be emphasized a little bit more
just before Dr
has a very important implication that
you need to have teachers with
specialist subject knowledge and as part
of our diversity in stem inquiry one of
the things we established is that in
stem subjects there is a shortage of
qualified teachers so that's that's that
adds to what's already been a problem
and you're a stem teacher would would
you agree with that there's two problems
to do with
um
with with this aspect so you have
teachers who are leaving the profession
in a short period of time which means
they haven't gained the subject
knowledge and then they're replaced by a
teacher at the very beginning of their
career which again they'd then need to
generate their subject knowledge
um and then the second part of the
problem is how is this disseminated down
and what does it look like for the
future because
uh teacher recruitment is is not doing
very well ITT recruitment is not doing
very well initial teacher training is
just not doing very well
um and if we end up with teachers who
are teaching non-special subjects then
it makes situations like that more able
to happen thank you sorry all right
is that
the point about it is
um right back to your initial premise
here that the two of you had produced a
piece of work of the same standards now
part of my job and all the checks and
balances I put in place are to make sure
that you would receive the same credit
for the quality of that answer so you
you wouldn't get a a lower mark
than your colleague because of teacher
expectation like that we would need to
do everything in to make sure that we
had the same issue what it might throw
up is that when I'm looking for
anomalies that highlight things that
look out of place
a piece of work where you've done much
better than you usually do probably
something that justifies greater
investigation because the outcome of you
using chat GPT has been something
outside the expectations and then we
have to be very careful to make sure
that we don't over oversell that so this
is again why I think it's so difficult
to spot where chat gbt is good because
simply the fact that you've done really
well isn't indication of you doing
anything other than working very hard on
this piece of work and the level of
expertise I need to be confident comes
from again talking to a teacher who's
taught you and can then do that great
investigation so it's
there's a potential challenge here to
say yes you'll get challenged on it more
likely because it looks like the order
but not that you would get a different
outcome
Just One Last Question
um so you you clearly embraced AI
particularly in terms of
processes and and everything else do you
think that there is
um any aspects of teaching where you do
not think AI
should be used anything pastoral so when
I was looking through where shouldn't
you put an AI pastel or was just an
instant one uh the care that we give to
pupils the small conversations that we
have with them when we build them
relationships that it just shouldn't
come anywhere close so for example if a
people has came to ahead of here and I'm
thinking in the dystopian if they came
to the head of the year with an issue
and they go on and they type in their
issue and they get how to fix that issue
and advice for that issue you're missing
a personal connection and the pupils
therefore then don't form social they
don't learn so it makes social
connections they don't mean empathy as
well they need to learn all these things
through a human that there's no two ways
about you can't learn empathy from a
computer
um and I think that's one thing that if
you were to to regulate anything it
shouldn't touch past oral because the
you need to highlight the importance of
the human connection between a teacher
or the support staff and and the student
themselves and um if you were to
introduce AI into that it just
you end up with pupils who what can may
end up in the future in this dystopian
future being cold with no empathy and
just mimic a computer so I think if all
of the different aspects pastoral needs
to be the one that we just make sure AI
does not touch
and I presume you agree with this one
well I I absolutely agree with that I
thought the previous point about levels
of risk is something that is really
challenging and where you have a huge
impact on a student of a decision that's
where I start being very nervous about
using artificial intelligence to make
that that judgment
um for example I think also in the case
of academic Integrity it may be a
wonderful tool to get evidence but it's
probably not the tool that we'd want to
use to make that final judgment I also
thought Rosie's previous comment about
difference between teaching and tutoring
is a really valuable one because at the
moment I think there's a lot more that a
teacher can bring than just the the
evidence that the artificial
intelligence can generate for the
teacher
thank you very much indeed we turn now
to Door Butler thank you chair thank you
for my A's traces
just pick it up on um something you said
in regards to I think as Joel who said
in regards to uh
children may be mimicking computers I I
had read actually that in Primary School
the teachers were having problems with
children who were just telling them to
do things because they were used to
talking to their Alexa and so there was
no please or thank you it was just
because that and you know and it was
very straight and
um and quite harsh and so they had to
kind of un unlearn that from them if
they want something done
um but I also think do you think that we
need to focus on teaching a lot more
critical thinking in schools now because
if
if young people are going to have to
decide
they're going to get some information
from AI in order for them to understand
that that might not be right or correct
then they're going to need to learn
political thinking skills right do you
agree
um Matthew
um absolutely and this isn't a change in
the IB philosophy we've always focused
on teaching those critical thinking
skills for example through our theory of
knowledge course and it's critical
thinking together with recognizing that
there are different forms of the truth
and why different people hold it and all
of that stuff it's not new it's always
been important but with artificial
intelligence I think it becomes even
more important and even more urgent that
people understand that right thank you
Joe and so
I have two two different perspective
perspectives one is
you can't I don't believe you can just
teach critical thinking if you can't
make a curriculum on critical thinking I
think that's a new one impossible to do
uh but what we as I do in science is we
have our ethical questions that we have
in science we have discussions to do
with Evolution and creationism
um alternative like Big Bang Theory
versus steady state Theory all of these
different types of conversations that
happen that makes them develop the
critical thinking maybe an emphasis
could be made on how that critical
thinking comes out in different topics
but I don't necessarily believe that you
can teach critical thinking as a
concrete one this is the curriculum for
critical thinking I think it forms a
part of the curriculum now and I do
think that we as teachers do teach
critical thinking could it be done more
yes I do believe it could
um and should AI Now sort of be brought
into it with let's say an AI is making a
decision should that decision be taken
by the AI or by a human yes these are
now new conversations that we can have
and but
the critical thinking is taught we teach
you all of the time maybe we should make
more of an emphasis on how that critical
the critical thinking is done and why
we're thinking them ways I do think
there needs to be more of a focus on
that
um but I do I do personally think that
we teach critical thinking we just need
to put more of a focus on it yeah
great thank you
um because I think that's also going to
help to people to identify the biases
that's in the system doesn't it
um can I can I ask you if there's a
difference between your vision of where
you see AI in education in 10 years and
what you think the reality might be so
what would you like
in regards to AI in the next 10 years
and what do you think will happen
so
what I would like to happen is for the
situation to remain quite similar but it
just becomes a new tool that we can use
and especially to do with feedback so if
I've got a classroom of 26 27 or 30
pupils in some extreme cases not in my
sense in my school but in certain
schools around the country where they're
pushing 30 to 33 and may it's impossible
to give the level of feedback that we
would like so in my ideal scenario and
when a pupil has answered a set of
questions the the way that they've
answered them questions could give
feedback on how to improve or maybe with
their tick box questions tells them a
topic that they should revise ideally
that's what I think it should go to and
but in
in reality I think it would
appear as a fat that people then start
using a few things appear and then the
ones that stick stay and then the rest
of them just fizzle away and this is
thinking about 10 years time and
there'll be programs that teachers can
use but they won't necessarily be the
best programs that we want I do think it
should be something that is made in
collaboration with with government and
with teachers and Educators that
we what do we want to get out of it we
want to reduce teacher-wire Cloud we
want to make sure pupils get good
feedback and we want to make sure that
assessment works and it's just if we
left it open in a vacuum I don't think
that would happen at all I think it
needs to be curated by by teachers and
and government as well so the reverse of
kind of what's happening now of course
um well if if you were to go on uh on
the media or on Twitter for example
you'd think that AI was taken over and I
don't necessarily believe it is I just
think it's it's being used more as a
tool and we need to work with them tools
and
again we we could end up into the into
the dystopia I don't think that's
happening I don't think we no one wants
the dystopia to happen and so
there are programs now that we use that
will or so I'm also an examiner fake QA
but we don't look at the tick boxes the
computer does that for us that is quite
a basic AI
um but that is a reducing of workload
and making processes easier we are
already using it we just need to use
that type of thing more I don't
necessarily think it's the opposite of
what's happening now because it is
happening now because it's used when
Market exams and it's used in in given
feedback for certain websites I do think
it's using I just think it's bringing it
more into the classroom doing a little
bit more often thank you thank you
um
I think artificial intelligence will be
used more and more behind the scenes of
organizations like my own with the other
exam boards to to do a lot of good stuff
there whether it's checking whether it's
understanding how things fit together
where my fear is that we won't see the
changes of society properly reflected in
where we change where we teach our
students and therefore
this dystopia future where people don't
critically think about statements enough
we've already seen that in some of the
social media posts we're already seeing
that in some of the
fake news debate I think the use of
artificial intelligence again it will
unless it's trained on the right and who
am I to Define what the right
information source is we're going to
find that snowballing and snowboarding
and I fear if we don't get ahead of the
curve with teaching students how to use
this software appropriately we we may
suddenly find ourselves in a very
dangerous position so it's exactly back
to your first point understand the bias
of their understand the critical
thinking understand the critical reading
that's what we need and it's it's not
critical thinking by itself you've got
to have a knowledge base to be able to
learn how to think critically but in
many ways it's knowledge-based
Independence it doesn't matter if you
learn it in this subject or that subject
you need to be able to take that across
all of the subjects and that's what
makes it I think a really good education
system it's not about teaching people to
be great biologists it's about teaching
people to be really great
Learners and thinkers and that's where
we need to get to thank you and last
questions
it's just I think what's important to
think of is what do you want your
education system to be do you want your
education system to be a you pass this
exam you do well or is your education
one that is that benefits the whole of
society the reason why we have our
education system now is to level the
playing field so every single person has
the access to their future that they
want in the past it was limited it was
based on the money that you had or the
connections that you had the reason we
have our education system now is we give
every single pupil in the entire country
the same the same resources the same
knowledge the same information in order
for them to do whatever it is that they
want in the future if we make it where
education is you learn this for X then
we we severely limit the impact that
education can actually have onto site on
wider Society education is for everyone
and it is to make sure that we have an
educated population that can make the
right decisions that can put people into
power that make the right decisions for
them
that's what education is for it's not a
tick box exercise it's about building a
bigger picture and we talk about
critical thinking and critical learning
that type of thing builds a good society
and that's what we need to make sure
that education focuses on I agree with
that although there is a lot of teaching
to the test that goes on but my last
question
um if you can make one suggestion to
government
uh as it consists as the future of AI
um in education specifically what would
it be
I can't resist responding to your
previous comment I'm sorry
teaching for the test does happen and so
what's an obligation on me as an
assessment person is to make sure that
the test is assessing what's really
important so by teaching to it we're
also teaching students what is really
important so yeah again backwash effect
on the assessment is so important
um I think that's what I would also say
to all education organizations and
people think of Education let's make
sure we are assessing what is important
and that's what is important perhaps
artificial intelligence will change a
little bit not
categorically but it will change what
the word what we need students to have
can we have education let's assess that
okay
one thing
um so if I was to ask if I was to say
anything to the government it is
try to think of a way
of implementing AI that doesn't
necessarily have a detrimental effect
and Publishing guidance and advice on
how schools and how organizations and
companies outside of Education can use
AI for the better by speaking with
people in the field by speaking with
experts to do with AI publishing advice
and guides and Pub to publish advice and
guidance on how to use it in the most
effective way and keep it out of certain
areas do not use it in XYZ for example
with pastoral thank you both very much
awesome thanks thank you thank you both
very much thank you for giving evidence
today it's been fantastic to hear from
practitioners you've really helped us
um as did the previous Witnesses develop
an understanding of some of the complex
implications of AI for Education we're
very grateful for that we'll return
usually your classroom into your
students Mr Kenyan
sureley
that concludes this meeting of the
committee order